there's an urban legend when grave
robbers found the way to ancient
Egyptian tombs there were warnings they
ignored do not open this tomb do not
steal the riches inside you'll be cursed
and you will die it's not true not just
that curses aren't real but those
warnings were just an urban legend
the robbers wouldn't have been able to
read them and even if they could the
messages weren't warning of curses they
were just the ancient equivalent of a no
trespassing sign
this is Alcala alto an island on the far
west of Finland and here they're
building a tomb for something that
really is dangerous in a few years the
deep bedrock here will contain the
world's first long-term storage site for
high-level nuclear waste right next to
some of the reactors that produce it
this isn't a video about where the
nuclear power is good or bad I think
it's good and so it seems to spin hland
the third reactor here is being tested
now and it's due to online next year but
this video is about a different question
we do have nuclear power in the world so
where do we put the waste
I didn't know how it feel until I stood
here it is very strange to have 400
meters of rock above my head and knowing
that inside that solid plugg of clay
there there is high-level radioactive
waste this new tunnel complex is called
uncle on which translates as cavity and
long-term storage really does mean
long-term a hundred thousand years to
put that in perspective a hundred
thousand years ago humans haven't made
it to Europe yet the continent was still
frozen in the middle of an ice age our
species were just hunter-gatherers this
facility is being designed to last for
geological time and yes despite the fact
that there are hundreds of nuclear
reactors in the world right now there is
no permanent geologic storage facility
anywhere for high-level radioactive
waste the spent nuclear fuel the really
nasty stuff that could cause disasters
if it leaks now the problem is an urgent
the world doesn't actually reduce that
much of it relatively speaking a
century's worth high-level waste from
all the plant reactors in Finland will
fit in the final version of this one new
facility but right now around the world
high-level radioactive waste is
generally stored near reactors first in
water ponds that require active cooling
and then in concrete casts that'll last
well that was long as a complete
building would not long enough the US
has been trying to work out the storage
side for years but that one serious
attempt Yucca Mountain has been mired in
politics for decades
Finland here it's closest to building
their solution
the geology in Finland is very old we
are talking about 2,000 million years is
the age of what we have below our feets
here and in that way it's really stable
and it represents the most ancient parts
of this high-level waste will be
disposed of with cast iron copper
canisters and the canisters are put into
the hole in the deposition tunnels and
the kneestr are surrounded by bentonite
clay clay has a low hydraulic
conductivity which means that the water
doesn't transport through the clay they
spent fuel when it's taking from the
reactors into the disposal it's highly
radioactive but with torrential
radioactivity will decrease after 500
years people can stand beside the
canister and it's not dangerous but
there are some other long-lived
radionuclides which might be harmful in
case they would come up to the surface
and into the drinking water into the
wells or biosphere and therefore the
Chia logical disposal will isolate the
waste for a hundred thousand of years
this area is prone to earthquakes or
other natural disasters geologically
it's about as peaceful as you can get so
the plan is dig the tunnels and then for
a hundred years
put the cast's of waste in and then
backfill each tunnel with clay so
they're encased in solid rock and once
the site is full fill in every little
bit every last tunnel and then leave it
forever there are multiple levels of
containment the idea is that even if one
or two of them fail everything will
still be safe for a hundred thousand
years
unless someone did sit-up when the US
government was thinking about using
Yucca Mountain as a storage site they
commissioned a now-famous report on how
to mark a site like this how do you warn
people away even if our civilization has
collapsed our language is falling apart
and no one knows what radiation is there
were all sorts of ideas from a spike
field to forbidding blocks but all of
those would ultimately be a big sign
saying hey there's something interesting
under here deep there's only this will
be boasted about 100 years six thousand
and five hundred tons for onion we are
not decided what is the best way of mark
that there was one other idea in that
research paper don't mark the site at
all once the repository is full fill it
in seal it shut and then hide it so
there's nothing remarkable on the
surface there are very few reasons to
dig this deep particularly here the odds
are slim that some future archaeologists
were designed to take 400 meters down in
this remote location and if they did if
someone ignored all the warnings or
arrived after everything that eroded
away up top well if they did break
through all the containment in search of
treasure what they get is radiation
poisoning and a particularly unpleasant
death if the grave robbers that dug up
Egyptian tombs had started rapidly and
obviously dying from a real curse maybe
they would have taken it
thank you so much to all the team that I
long to have showed me and all the
camera teams who are down here today
around you can find out more about them
in the links in the video description
all right thank you your turn